[Music]  has your voice ever cracked oh man one  night late night partying in Tijuana we  had a big fight the next day and I was  uh I was very bored how long did it take  you to grow your hair out that length I  have not cut my hair since 1988 so 34  years what do you not like about your  job oh I hate getting up early in the  morning after a big fight in heaven it's  great to have to go to all the cities  but sometimes  the fight night's so exciting the After  parties are incredible and then you got  that early flight that's rough can you  demonstrate your voice prep before you  head out to the ring yes  Cuban cigar  who's the coolest celebrity you've ever  met  not only did I get to meet him but I got  to work with him and spend time with  them I love Sugar Ray Leonard if one  celebrity were to take your job who do  you think has the voice for it oh that's  easy that's James Earl Jones